[Music]
Min, what's wrong with you, Senpai? You've
done it again. The
medicine is
running away again.
Taro: This is a side effect of the medicine. Did you
intend to treat me like that? No, that
's a medicine that girls shouldn't take.
However, men's desires tend to lead to physical pleasure, which is
good, but women's sexual desires tend to lead to
mental pleasure, which means kissing.Therefore, they
shouldn't have been allowed to kiss anymore.  The
four of them are now completely dependent on their instinct to kiss, and the
limiters of reason have been removed, and their
physical abilities are on full display.They ca
n't think of anything but kissing the person they love, and they lose their sense of self.They are, so to speak, kissing
zombies.  Dachichu
chichi